Speaker 1: OK, let's get to a few other stories.
There's been a lot of talk from Donald Trump about
his record in endorsing people, and it'll be
interesting to see with Glenn Youngkin winning
in Virginia. How much credit Donald Trump takes
Trump taking a moment during his interview with
Jeanine Pirro over the weekend to say I endorsed
Youngkin and I endorsed him strongly. I assure
you of and had lost, Trump would have said, Well,
I endorsed him, but he didn't really embrace me
young and did win. And presumably Trump is going
to take credit there. Trump's record is actually
not that great on endorsements, but not only
from a numbers standpoint. Trump's also endorsed
some really horrible people. One such person
appears to be Senate candidate Sean Parnell,
who now is accused by his wife of strangling her
and beating their children. There's a report in
Rolling Stone about this, which says wife of
Trump backed Senate candidate Sean Parnell
claims he strangled her, beat their children.
Estranged wife Laurie Snell also alleged the
Republican candidate told her to go get an
abortion. Lori Snell, the estranged wife of
Pennsylvania Senate candidate Sean Parnell,
testified during a court hearing on Monday,
alleging that her husband strangled her. Parnell
denies this also made other claims. Her testimony,
which alleged both verbal and physical abuse, took
place during a hearing in Butler, Pennsylvania,
in a child custody proceeding over their three
children in their divorce case. She had previously
sought temporary protective orders against
Parnell in 2017 and 2018, although both were
later expunged. Former President Donald Trump
endorsed Sean Parnell in September for his run
in the Republican primary. Parnell is vying for
Pennsylvania's open Senate seat in 2022 in what's
shaping up to be one of the most hotly contested
Senate races next year. That is a big race,
she said. He tried to choke me out on a couch and
I literally had to bite him. He was strangling me.
In another incident, she claimed Parnell
slapped one of the children so hard
it left visible fingerprint shaped welts. She
also testified he was verbally abusive and another
incident she alleged he forced her out of her
vehicle and told her to go get an abortion. Now
that's politically relevant because on Parnell's
campaign website, he states, I am pro-life,
will always vote to protect the unborn.
If true, and these are allegations,
if true, it would be another instance of hypocrisy
of a gap between stated values and how they
actually live in real life. In a statement issued
by the campaign, Parnell denied the allegations
and said he would present the truth to the court
next week. Let me emphatically state I have never
raised a hand in anger towards my wife or any of
our three children. What happened today in court
was not justice, nor did it have any basis, in
fact or truth now. A lot of people will write to
me. They'll say, David, how you know, you can't
say these things happened. These are allegations
which have been refuted, and that's absolutely
and completely fine. I'm more interested
in the reality, the undeniable reality that these
types of allegations, even when proven credible,
no longer torpedo your chances. At least if you're
a Republican, we've actually seen you could argue
to a fault. Over the last decade, the Al Franken
incident is arguably one of these situations where
Democrats hold their own to very
different standards than Republicans.
And there was a time when something like
this would kill your shot at winning,
and times have really changed. You could argue
that a key moment in this trajectory was when the
Access Hollywood tape came out with Donald Trump
talking about When you're famous, they just let
you do it. You just grab them by the, you know
what? Nothing happened. Nothing happened. There
was a time when that could have ended a campaign.
Today, it won't even necessarily get Donald Trump
to revoke his endorsement of you. For now, Donald
Trump has not revoked his endorsement of Sean
Parnell. I wouldn't expect him to for the time
being. Help Sean Parnell could end up being the
Republican presidential candidate. This wouldn't
even necessarily disqualify him from that. So it
is very much the case that the Pennsylvania Senate
race is going to be a big, big deal in 2022.
The 2022 elections in the United States are
going to be wide ranging and important. There
are actually a number of seats Pennsylvania. Ohio,
maybe, maybe Missouri, North Carolina and Alabama,
where there are retiring Republican senators,
retiring Republican senators. Doesn't mean a
Democrat can win, but it at least will not be a
Democrat going up against an incumbent, and those
are real opportunities. And as we've talked before
about the Joe Manchin problem, I continue to say
the way to fix the Senate is by flipping some red
states blue. It's not by primary Manchin and then
having whoever defeats Manchin. If anybody lose
to a Republican in the general in West Virginia,
it's just it's literally not a solution in that it
actually gives Republicans an additional seat. So
we're going to keep an eye on the Sean Parnell
allegations and other beauty of an endorsement
from Donald Trump. These are just allegations for
the time being, just important to mention that